okay so hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm very sick again yes I
was sick last week but I woke up this
morning after I returned from New York
went to the doctor discovered this I
have a double ear infection that means I
have an infestation of bacteria in both
of my ears I'm not even joking I have so
many medications that they gave you for
this and I'd like something to shoot up
my nose something to slam in my ears and
this crap which is just Boop that I'm
supposed to gargle there's no way to
gargle it cuz and it's supposed to make
things numb like medical do anyway I'm
just kind of sitting among all the cool
stuff that people have given over time
all these ALPA castles as they think
they're cool here feel adorable and
these demon toys that other people would
give me no go back whatever the hell you
are from that show that I don't know
anyway like I said I guess just get back
from New York and yes I'm sick it is the
worst feeling in the world to not be
able to make videos like I would want to
especially have to be busy for so long
and not being home so I can record and
after just moving into my new place and
then coming back from New York on a
business trip that didn't actually mean
anything I didn't really need to be down
there but if you could get to hang out
with jontron here's a video of me
enjoying the grandiosity that is New
York
Marx laughing today I kid just did a
hyeyeon Oh some wasn't it a lot of fun
but either way I would rather than back
home and I imagine that I picked this up
when I was over there in New York which
is just fantastic but either way I'm
back and yes the charity livestream is
still on for this Saturday it's three
days away Bob and Wade are both going to
be in attendance not only are we doing
our normal merchandise but we're also
going to be doing more giveaways this
time for you lovely people out there
raising money for AbleGamers which is a
very good charity that focuses on
developing disabilities related to
peripherals for people who have
disabilities you can't gain normally or
making sure the games have color blind
mode or disabled mode or something along
those lines of the people of all you
know abilities can play games so I don't
know the correct terminology right now
but my brain is not working but either
way it's a really good charity to find
out more about able to description below
we're going to be selling merchandise
and doing straight up donations and for
everyone who is in attendance and there
was so many people last month with like
46,000 people there we're going to be
doing another giveaway we were giving
away iPod Touches with special
engravings the red iPod Touch which also
donates money to AIDS research and they
were arrived with marklars heroes Iran
just bear with me I'm gonna get to the
point here but this time we're going to
be doing something else so that I don't
have to ship them out manually and do
international tribute all that we're
going to be giving away Amazon gift
cards 50 bucks apiece and some hundred
dollar gift cards and I'm going to try
to give away 100 gift cards so that more
people who are in attendance can win
more things now there's no thing that
you need to do necessarily for this to
be entered into the
able to do I cannot say words right now
oh oh in my little biscuit you're not it
that's ok trying about 1000 so all I
need to do is be there at the live
stream you just need to be active in
chat we'll be able to pick your name out
of a random slot budget and then we'll
send you a gift card through email
directly that way you'll be able to get
it meeting the users bang zoom you're
done done so hope you guys can be there
we're going to be giving away a lot more
now I'm going to try to go the full time
of the livestream but if I'm still sick
I hope you guys can understand that I
might have to duck out earlier ended
early but I will try my best power food
I will slug down an entire bottle of
cold medicine so that the entire live
stream I'm loopy as hell and not that
I'm not loopy right now because I'm on
four different types of medications but
you get the idea so anyway I did move
into a new place I have not had a chance
to do anything in the new place I
haven't even been a chance unpacked
really I'm still working on pretty much
everything a home tour might be down the
road a little bit if you don't remember
I did a home tour of my last place
here's like 10 video to be gyrating
outside
if Jesus
well it's pretty cool anyway so as soon
as I have some free time because it is
just killing you not being able to have
some free time not just to make videos
for you guys which is big stress on me
right now
not being able to make as many videos as
I would like now for you guys but not
being able to it for myself like the
flights over to New York kill it at like
five and a half hours and I was only
there like a day and a half and like
right back I spend all the weekend prior
moving and then I was sick last week I
mean it's just like I'm very much
looking forward to the next month
because I don't have anything scheduled
for next month and I don't want to
schedule anything for next month so I'm
very much looking forward to just kind
of relaxing which would be very nice but
either way until then I'm still going to
be working my butt off for you guys and
I just want to say thank you guys so
much for supporting me through
everything you know it periods where our
videos are kind of short or laxing and
some of them are short but you know
where I would like to put out more and
you guys still are supporting me and
telling me that I still need to take a
break I'm not going to do that but I
appreciate it unless you guys are you
guys are literally everything this
channel is literally
so I want to make sure that I do
everything that I can to make the best
that I can so just from the bottom of my
heart thank you guys so much for your
ongoing support and everything that
you've done
I tell me I can't wait see Bob and wait
again hopefully they'll be around long
enough so that we can afford some cool
stuff so thanks again everybody for
watching if I forgot everything anything
at all in this video you check the
description just make sure I so thank
you and as always I will see you in the
next video